Well, hello everyone,
my name is Reynoso, I'll be developing the
front-end, I've been working at MercadoLibre
for a little over a year now.
responsibility because everything we
do ends up impacting an
unimaginable number of users for those who
do not know free market, we are
the leading commerce platform in
Latin America and we have a lot of
visits all the time, so
everything we end up doing impacts a large
number  As I was saying, incredible,
that's why I think we have a
motto or we try to live by a motto, an
objective that pleases
us and all things and the most
important thing for us is always to
put the user's needs
first, even above
our own, as  developers
and speaking of users and always for
more first a little is
related to what I want to tell you
there cr  So what about talking about users and
happy users I think well I think
we all know what a happy user is
we all want to be
happy users and a happy user I think they
love having a website or fast that is
even if they are part of a website  or
fast
a happy user but we really know
that it is a fast website we call it a
fast website
here I distinguish between two categories on the one
hand that the site is literally
fast that is let's say that it loads
fast loading times are short and on the
The other side is that the user perceives that
the site is fast, which does not mean that
the site is
fast, but something is wrong with the user, he
understands that the site itself is fast, and
now that the keyword comes, which is
perception,
speaking a bit of  perception i
would like us to go back to the year
1993 jakob nielsen which is a group of
toys for those who do not know him
one of his books told us a little
about the limits of perception  that is,
how the user reacts over time to
the response, for example, an application
or a website
about these times in perception are
break points,
the first is 100 milliseconds 0.1
seconds, which is in which the user
will feel that the response  that it is
receiving is instantaneous
then we have a second that is
from this point where we start a little
to give the user's attention their train
of thought is going to start to
deviate and and then it is already the limit of 10 seconds
that if we really still have  some
user who is interested in
fulfilling the objective that was wanting to
make fun of us we will have
completely lost and begin to feel even
frustration about what they are having
done I think we were all there
I don't know who has endured and for today 10
seconds with  a blank page
so we understand what
our limits are and how the user
understands and reacts to this I think
a little bit  we can
figure out where we want it to be more or less useful by
showing some kind of visual acid
I think this happens around the
second the second we have to give the
user
a warning that something is
happening
ok
understood more or  minus the perception and
the times that we have in our pothole
let's say and see how we can
optimize it for that we have
to understand what is happening we have
to know what is happening with the
rendering for here it is a little bit that is
what is the  render impact we know what
we are talking about
so well what are we really talking about
in very general terms
basically that is to say for example we
organize an action we click a link
whatever it is we get a url and we give it a
sit on what happens until what the
browser does until  complete from
rendering on screen to our
web page for example
in very general terms but it
is simply the path that the
n  The browser performs a series of
events that meet to reach this
goal and that is in very generic terms,
but what is it all about?
Let's do the steps one by one, there are seven steps that they perform to accomplish the rendering puff and now we are going to see
hence, how to detach criticism of the
impact render that only they have also
heard him speak,
the first thing he is going to do basically is to
generate a network request out
a lot of things do not happen there is a in that
place if you have a cpi connection that
's good  finally send
http request here
between a little and a little we have
approximately 600 milliseconds in
which we do not have much control
over what is happening
ok let's imagine that everything is fine with
the request the service what it is going to do
is give us a response
depending  our role a little as you
want to have a little part in what
the answer may take but
well let's imagine that it helps Serbian already
answered us d  io in html now some
progress in what would be the critical
rendering for the critical part that the
user, sorry, that the browser
fulfills to reach the goal of
rendering on the screen and all this
begins with the processing of the html
I imagine that we have the answer that we
dio are 8000 it's super simple what
the browser is going to be it's going to be process it
from top to bottom
what you need to do is translate it the
browser what it's going to do then is
generate the gift to everyone I think we know
what it is what it is  a map of nodes in
which
all those
connections are going to be put together, what it is going to be then is to
translate, for example, it is found in
any such meeting, it begins,
volunteer, title, the markets, etc., it
turns them into new maps, on
Sunday, a  point that, for
example, finding a link tag with
a reference to an external css resource
what it is going to do at this point is going to
stop this process that is performing
the processing  or from the html and once it
receives the response from the css then it will
start processing what happened here is
that what the browser understands is what
it needs to render on the
screen, so what it does is
absolutely stop what it is doing  it is
what we call blogging
and then start processing and it works
quite similarly with html to have
all the rules, all the instructions
and it will also convert them into
other more good ones like the one that is the
session in which it is also good  it will
end with everything processed in nodes
one is that I will end with that it will
return to the previous process or it will
continue processing the html
surely the css is in one process the other
will process it again it will return
until  it finishes other things that what
in the render are good there is also a
script that is both an external resource and
something internal and pretty mental for example
and one such for example good once the
processes are finished  ar the html what is going
to happen is the following it is
going to start generating around wheat
that we only hear the
name speak and it tells us a lot on the one hand that there
are 3 it will tell us that its
map of nodes also and the randers  it is the
part that is actually going
to end up rounding on the screen
what is visible, that is why here in the render
tree what it is going to do is combine the
other two trees that it generated
previously and it is going to
combine them or  it is to unify the relationships
that they have with each other, that is why in the
randers and they are going to end up locating
all the things that are going to be
visible and I insist what is inside
the body and well there are some parks that
are included for example that never go  to
be rendering leds on screens I don't know
all the write all of you
etcetera and apart as its name says it
is what it is to render on screen and
we are also combining the
ss instructions there are things that are going to
exclude us with eleme  ntos that are in
the gift when excluding the render tree from the
render as everything you have
display no for example changes will not end up
appearing
one is that it already has everything processed which
is what will end up rendering on
screen is going to happen  a
layout outline and also known as
read flow that basically what it is going to
do is
size everything in the newport it is going to
interpret all the according to the rules
that all the elements have applied it is
going to calculate the positions etc. and
all the sizes  All this part of the
processing, once you have it
ready and super cooked, what you are going to do
is paint it on the screen. It sounds very
simple, but these times, well, it can
take more or less. We know that there are
properties, etc., that are a little more
expensive to paint than  others but well
in the end everything will end up painted
ok
until we understand a little about what
the process is here it ends here
finally we are going to have
visual content in the  screen one is that
we understand what all this is about we
understood which is also critical with that part,
which is to say everything that was
after the answer forward
is everything that it does not do itself
to render on screen
once we understand more  or less
how these steps work and
develop we can see how we can
optimize them
[Music]
these are a couple of little tips that is, they are
very basic things surely many of
these things are already being done
but well they will end up helping us
save a few moments  in the load on the
one hand let's try to pack our
assets we already know that if it is a long
time that it comes across something what it is going
to do is stop everything and go look for it if
we give it as few opportunities as
possible so that we are going to end up
saving a  little time
is surely going by today is that we have the
winds on one side our
own things on the other and the truth is that we
are not benefiting pr  It is preferable to have
everything packaged in the minimum amount
possible and that no one now requests except
on the other hand
this is great the remains
are not yet many standards but it is good
for them to investigate them so that
they take them into account basically what
they are going to do is indicate  value when using
things that we are going to end up needing
in the future, which is why
one of the processes is going to be advanced,
investigate first with the dns perfetti and first
what we are going to see now a
little bit can you give us a hand well
that's it  super audio
let's try whenever we can what
obviously happens for this basically is
the advice let's not write on the
gel and lastly it
means more difficult we see where
possible all our assets this is
going to save us bytes for whatever reason or
translate in time
ok
from there how the criticize
of the impact is clear we saw a little how to
optimize it
but well I promised them that I was going to
come to talk about dss and how it is  It has had an
impact on performance, so if
you remember a little bit of what I
told you at the beginning of the two classes
of fast websites,
the first part would be like fulfilling the
first point, you have to make the site that
is really a little faster and  I
think that the essence part that I
am going to tell you now plays for the second
side, which is to deceive the
user's perception a little to make him
believe that the site is really
really a little faster,
this is where he comes in to save the day
criticize the css
this is a technique
before I start to tell you what
they are about I would like to make a
clarification because many times we are
the first one that we are repeating
criticize all the time and it is super
confusing on the other hand we are talking
about criticize css is criticized  peace there
is not a lot of things that
end up mixing so much what we
are really talking about
then a critical path basically
we are talking about the path that
r  echo the browser to meet the
objective of rendering css, that is, only the
name tells us that we are within the path
of the path and on the other hand criticism ss
is the technique we have to improve
that path
we always try to think of it as
if one goes above the  another improving
and improving the way and we also
tried it is critical they sound like super
negative it sounds like something bad but it
is not the truth that it is not it
is simply a synonym of what would
be something vital necessary indispensable
if you want you can think of it as vital
ccs  instead of criticizing so as not to
confuse us so much with the names but
well now we are going to see why it is
called criticism etc
let's think for example well this is the
product page in mercadolibre which
is what the user is going to give in the first
stage this  that I like to call it the
initial screenshot what the user
is going to see first when he enters
the page he is looking at in this in the
publishing world is  you know it as the
folk voice only they also know it
that way basically what we want to
do with this technique
if this is the first thing that the user is going to see
is the only thing that we should
load him for which our
critical styles or our vital styles or
necessary are these only those that
comply with this part this portion of the view
port
that is why I think the translation would be
like the styles necessary for our
view of the web in a way
hello let's imagine that we already defined
what those styles are we have them super
cooked are these then  I said
the only thing we have to send to the
browser so that it learns and
then the only thing we should load
in the head are the only styles the
critical styles
now and then if we stop to think for
a second if we see a little bit of when
we talk about rendering peace  and that they
block it if we have these styles in
a separate band but not an
external file we would be a bit late
Little in the times then I think that
what we are going to have to do
is what many people do not
like and they always told us not to
do it, which is to put styles in line on
the gel,
this must be the reaction of many
because  before moving on why
about the rest of our styles
before that let's see why we think the
second basically what we don't want
is for the browser to have absolutely
everything necessary
if we leaving the styles in girl are
already going to have everything in the first  html that it
receives, so the rendering time is
going to be much less
now what happens with the rest of
our styles, that is, if the user
starts to interact, they will see content
that was not studied, which is not what
we want  This is where
a little bit of javascript magic comes into play that
will help us basically what
we want to do is because
we only put it in the critical styles in the
head what we are going to do  is that when
the page finishes downloading everything is to
go find the rest of our styles and
put them in the browser what it is
going to do is interpret the change and
simply what it is going to do is go
find them reuse them on the screen
etcetera by  which by the time
the user begins to
interact with each other, there will be final content
but we don't care,
so the user
is not interested in what he is seeing in the end
because he is not interacting
with that, ok what  is what we are going to gain
then what is a bit of what
we were talking about before we are going to gain the
perception of the loading time of the
page the user as I told them what he is
going to see is content that is for him it is
final no matter how  it is not, we are not
cheating a little but well he is not
going to realize
there are a couple of things that we have to
take into account also on the one hand
we are depending on the hash creep
for which probably some
usu base  years in which we are leaving
out now knowing what we
have to do in these cases, but
well, let's take into account and on the other hand
on the other hand if
our online styles are always first,
our critical online styles are not
going to be  Putting what is super
important, which is the browser cache,
which basically what it will allow us to do
is speed up subsequent visits and the
user has already downloaded the
final styles, the ideal is that
we always show him that because it will be
much faster  that the browser
will fetch it from the user's machine,
although we are always printing
online styles that will never be
nearly efficient,
let's say what we have to
do is save that data from silverio
carbon headquarters, that is, if Javier already
styles  critics is now we
are also going to see how we are going to do it
ok up to this point I think we were
seeing a little bit what the theory
of the technique would be like now we are going to  see a
little bit of the ways we have to
put it into practice first let's see how
we are going to load these critical styles
there is a production on the one hand the
javascript script now I am going to
show you a little bit of a
cast implementation although it would be the basic thing we have
to do  but also the plugins such as
logs and if it did it is that it
is surely well known you can search for it it is something
very simple basically what we are
doing is listening to the windows logo
and in the color what we are going to do is
create a link element put a  couple of
attributes so that the browser understands
that they are style sheets with the passage to
our final audio styles and
finally learning that when we give help is
nothing very complicated
on the other hand remember that the challenge that
richard told you a little about people
this is great  pri what is not
even close to being standard but it
can be used in the latest
versions of chrome anyway this is
something to go  putting as a
progressive improvement without we are going to have to have
a [ __ ] it
's great man I love them if
they want us and they get to know him it's a
normal link
basically the only change is the king
that he's going to be instead of this situation and
he's going to have it  He goes to our
final styles and what the players interpreted,
which, as it is a prologue, what you are
going to do is then go
search synchronously and not what the
render was, well, we also have to indicate
that it is why this is also  it works
for javascript
if it didn't come to me and it has events for
which what we are going to do is simply
the moment it finishes loading that
file we simply discard it
as a black stage when interpreting it it
is a stretched sheet it is going to process it
to function quietly as it
would normally, it's great,
investigate them and you can apply them,
use them
and good also with the space before
now we also have to make a tip  or
to check if the user already has
our final styles for this we are going
to make a cookie and we did not have
much option other than to do it from the
server side the check do me for
the case of the example we are using php
but it basically works for anything
if you already have the cookie and if
the cookie is the same as our version
because I also don't know that we have versioned styles we
want you to always have
grab the latest version what we are going
to do if you already have it because you have already visited
and seen the critical styles
we put  our links to our
final styles but what we have to
do is basically the technique we put
our critical styles online and
well we do more or less the same
check by javascript we load our
critical styles and save in the
top that it already has has its styles
seen
and  well also lastly what I was
telling you before that we depend on hacker
and for which we have to have a forum
for users  rivers that do not have
javascript enabled because if we are not
going to give them a poor experience
they will give half of the things so
nothing just a script of our
our final styles and
that's it ok now that they are no less we saw how to
load them
let's see  I think the most tedious part
is the generation of these
critical styles. I distinguish between two
categories by one. We have the
automatic self-magic tools,
as I like to tell you, they
can be good reviews and that is
penthouse penthouse also has an
online generator and critical basically they
are  their dnpm modules
so implementing them in our course
should be super simple what
they do in theory basically
just a series of super
configurable parameters and from that they extract the
styles of our page very
magically
on the other hand if we use a pre
processor
it can be salt and light suns or whatever and
we have a good one does the code if
our styles  they are super motorized
on Sundays everything is separated in
parayas everything is very componentized what we are going
to do is simply tell you to
understand what our
critical styles are for the type of view
add branches and we generate our own
band
of component styles  that are going to be seen
in a default web
in my experience the second option is
the best basically it is the one that
scales best for projects at least in
large projects that where we apply it
simply requires having a good
code base that is to be well
thought out  from the beginning and then it
comes out I just flow only because it
will quietly generate I know
later on the other hand the
automated tools are very
good I think it is not for a type of
simple projects with very
static pages with little maintenance of
styles where because apart  it is very
tied to the url for example in
mercadolibre we have super
dynamic networks for which m  Many of them are not useful to us
and also the size of the view
, which is why in some cases it is super
limiting for them. I already told you a
little bit now we are going to talk about how we
implement critical css in
mercadolibre
we began to think about a bit of criticism at the
end of last year  I am going to tell you
a little about the first experience we
had in implementing it, and I will tell you in advance
that it was not good, but later so
that it is not all so bad, I will tell you that
later we also implemented it in several
other places with a little bit of a
happier experience.  but well let's see where
we did it this first time
surely capable then I don't know if
this part looks very good well obviously
free marking is the
search listings and it's a good mobile that was
where we had the greatest need to
improve
performance simply  view it seems very simple there are very
few critical styles that
we should have but what the list has that you are
looking for is super dynamic
we have d  different types of views
we have filters we have
other times another type of view we have
banners we have official stores
we have a lot of variables and together with
superauto combinable so it is very
random and ccoo where the user can get
that's why well there at that point when
we start  to do the implementation the
truth is that it had we are about to
start the redesign which is the version
that we had just seen it was the previous version
and apart from that well the workflow that
we had was not very well oiled either it
was very green no no that did not
allow us to have  automated tools
and puts the modularized
styles not even close to what we had,
so it is something that we did have very
well in decline, which is why I think
we made the worst possible decision,
we generated our styles online
when we had a super handmade way of
own code in our  own
bookshelf and then we just put in that online
blender,
that is, they crossed and finished
Approximately with more than 20
different compilations for all the
versions that we found later, we
found that once we got
out of production, we continued to
find steps that we had not
contemplated at first, but well, you
can imagine that this resulted in a
total mess and equally to  this point yes that
is one of those traces of this point
we were happy the truth is that
everything was going more or less well the
problem actually started when
we started to put fixes officers in
our old code so we had
to regenerate absolutely all
our critical styles  for all the
houses because we didn't know where it
could hit and we ended up
with
the worst experience from the development point
of view that we had at
least since I've been in the free market
[Music]
and well
basically nothing became impossible  to
maintain for that is the end point
what it means equally for us
results  You are incredible, even though the
experience has been quite bad,
the version of lips and well this is a
comparison of the before and after
basically
we started to see content in the version
with criticism at 1.4 seconds
while in the previous version
we just started at  2.5 to see the logo and
as you will see it is
going to finish, there are already 56 better ones and
I will tell you in advance
how you will see it ends the four points 5
while the previous
finished version receives the 4.9 which is
only 8% improvements in real
loading time
that means good you go ahead a 56
percent improvement in the perception
of loading time is not the real load
of the site is we enter the second
category and from the business point of view
we improve the conversion rate by 2%
that may sound  super little
but in mercadolibre the bar that is a
lot where it is very rare that something that
something that we implement at this level of
front-end for example ended up creating
so much in the conversion
so well then what we saw was
a little about the criticism of the css and
how that together with other optimizations
layoffs is basically going to end up
in a total profit it was very much for the
users because for them the page
loaded 56 percent faster it was  a
good one for us for the company in
general because we ended up selling more
for us it wasn't so much a win as
developers because I already told you
that we had a bit of a bad time but well I think
that all in all it ended up being a
win so nothing crazy I would like it to be
Take away from this talk that I
told you about, it's a little bit like what technique is about,
as they can take away with their
own projects, but above
all things, I would like them to take away a
little bit about the focus on speed, that
is, the important thing.  which is that we think about
dispatch and performance and how this
ends up also impacting the
experience of our users that I do
remember in the motto at the beginning
should  be what we always put
first thank you
[Applause]